o prejuicio implícito.
Y eso resulta en una falta de diversidad muy perjudicial
en nuestro mundo laboral
y especialmente en áreas de importancia.
Hola, Gabinete Federal de Australia.
(Aplausos)
Permítanme establecer algo desde el principio:
el sesgo inconsciente no es lo mismo que la discriminación consciente.
No estoy diciendo que en todos Uds. haya oculto un sexista o racista
al acecho, esperando para salir.
Eso no es lo que estoy diciendo.
Todos tenemos nuestros prejuicios.
Son filtros a través de los cuales vemos el mundo que nos rodea.
No estoy acusando a nadie,
el sesgo no es una acusación.
Más bien, es algo que tiene que ser identificado,
reconocido y combatido.
El sesgo puede ser sobre la raza, puede ser sobre el género.
También puede ser sobre la clase social, la educación, la discapacidad.
El hecho es que todos tenemos prejuicios contra lo diferente,
lo diferente a nuestras normas sociales.
La cosa es que, si queremos vivir en un mundo
donde las circunstancias del nacimiento
no dicten el futuro
y donde la igualdad de oportunidades esté generalizada,
entonces todos y cada uno de nosotros tenemos un papel que jugar
en asegurarnos que el sesgo inconsciente no determina nuestras vidas.
Existe un conocido experimento en el ámbito del sesgo inconsciente
y que está relacionado con el género en los años 1970 y 1980.
Las orquestas, por aquel entonces eran mayoritariamente de hombres,
y solo un 5 % eran mujeres.
Al parecer, eso se debía a que los hombres tocaban de manera diferente,
presumiblemente mejor, presumiblemente.
Pero en 1952, la Orquesta Sinfónica de Boston realizó un experimento.
Hicieron audiciones a ciegas.
Así que en lugar de audiciones cara a cara,
uno tenía que tocar detrás de una pantalla.
Curiosamente, no se observó ningún cambio inmediato
hasta que se pidió a los aspirantes que se descalzaran
antes de entrar en la habitación.
Porque el clic-clac de los tacones
sobre el suelo de madera
era suficiente para descubrir a las damas a distancia.
Una vez hecho esto,
los resultados de la prueba mostraron
que había un 50 % más de probabilidades
de que una mujer superara la etapa preliminar.
Y casi se triplicaron sus posibilidades de pasar la prueba.
¿Qué nos dice eso?
Bueno, por desgracia para ellos,
los hombres realmente no tocaban de manera diferente,
pero existía la percepción de que lo hacían.
Era el sesgo el que determinaba el resultado.
Así que aquí
identificamos y reconocemos que existe un sesgo.
Y miren, todos lo hacemos.
Déjenme darles un ejemplo.
Un hijo y su padre sufren un horrible accidente de tráfico.
El padre muere en el impacto
y el hijo, que está gravemente herido, es trasladado al hospital.
El cirujano examina al hijo cuando llega y dice:
"No puedo operar".
¿Por qué?
"El niño es mi hijo".
¿Cómo puede ser eso?
Señoras y señores,
el cirujano es su madre.
Ahora levanten la mano --y no pasa nada--
levanten la mano si supusieron al principio que el cirujano era hombre.
No hay evidencia de que existe sesgo inconsciente,
pero solo tenemos que reconocer que está allí
y luego buscar formas para poder combatirlo
y para que podamos buscar soluciones.
Una de las cosas interesantes
que rodean al sesgo inconsciente es el tema de las cuotas.
Y esto es algo que a menudo se comenta.
Y muchas de las críticas es esta idea de mérito.
Mira, yo no quiero ser elegida porque soy chica,
quiero ser elegida por mis méritos,
porque soy la persona indicada para el trabajo.
Es un sentimiento bastante común entre las ingenieras
con las que trabajo y que yo sepa.
Y sí, lo entiendo, he pasado por eso.
Pero, si la idea del mérito es cierta,
¿por qué al enviar currículos idénticos en un experimento
realizado en 2012 por la Universidad de Yale,
currículos idénticos enviados para un puesto de técnico de laboratorio,
¿por qué se considerará a Jennifer menos competente,
será menos probable que obtenga el trabajo,
y cobrará menos que John?
El sesgo inconsciente está ahí,
pero solo tenemos que mirar cómo podemos combatirlo.
Y, saben, es interesante,
hay investigaciones que explican
por qué es así y se lo llama paradoja del mérito.
Y en las organizaciones --y esto es un poco irónico--
las organizaciones que hablan del mérito como su principal motor
a la hora de contratar,
eran más propensas a contratar hombres y a pagar más a los chicos
porque al parecer el mérito es una cualidad masculina.
Pero, oye.
Así que piensan que me han calado,
y que saben que pasa aquí.
¿Se imaginan que puedo encargarme de uno de estos?
¿Pueden imaginarse andar por allí y decir
"Oye, chicos, esto es lo que hay. Así es cómo se hace".
Bueno, me alegro de que puedan.
(Aplausos)
Porque señoras y señores, ese es mi trabajo diario.
Y lo bueno de esto es que es bastante entretenido.
En lugares como Malasia,
hablar de mujeres musulmanas que trabajen en plataformas
ni siquiera se contempla.
Hay muchas. Pero, es entretenido.
Me acuerdo que le decía a uno de los chicos,
"Oye, colega, quiero aprender a surfear".
Y me decía: "Yassmin, no sé cómo vas a surfear
con todo esa equipo que llevas,
Y no conozco ninguna playa solo para mujeres".
Y entonces, el chico vino con una idea brillante,
algo así como, "Sé que diriges esa organización
Jóvenes sin Fronteras, ¿no?
¿Por qué no creas una línea de ropa de playa para jóvenes musulmanas
Puedes llamarla "Juventud Sin Bañadores".
(Risas)
Y le dije, "Gracias, chicos".
Y recuerdo a otro chico que me dijo
que debo comer todo el yogur que pueda
porque esa era la única cultura en la cual me iba a mover.
Pero, el problema es que es un tanto verdad
porque hay una gran falta de diversidad en nuestro mundo laboral,
particularmente en puestos de influencia.
Ahora, en 2010,
La Universidad Nacional de Australia hizo un experimento
donde se enviaron 4000 solicitudes idénticas
para puestos de trabajo no cualificados, esencialmente.
Para obtener el mismo número de entrevistas
que alguien con un nombre anglosajón,
si fueran chinos, tendrían que enviar un 68 % más de solicitudes.
Si fueran de Medio Oriente --Abdel-Magied--
deberían enviar un 64 % más,
y si fueran italianos, es muy afortunado,
es suficiente con enviar solo un 12 % más.
En lugares como Silicon Valley, no es mucho mejor.
En Google, publicaron los datos de diversidad:
el 61 % son blancos, el 30 % asiáticos,
y el 9 % negros, hispanos,
todo ese tipo de gente.
En el resto del mundo de la tecnología no es mucho mejor,
lo reconocen,
pero no estoy realmente segura qué están haciendo al respecto.
Y no tienen ningún efecto.
En un estudio realizado por Green Park,
--un proveedor británico importante de altos ejecutivos--
arrojó que más de la mitad de las empresas FTSE 100
no tienen un líder no blanco en su junta directiva,
ejecutivo o no ejecutivo.
Y dos de cada tres no tienen un ejecutivo
que pertenezca a una minoría.
Y la mayoría de las minorías que se encuentran en ese tipo de nivel
son consejeros no ejecutivos.
Así que no tiene mucha influencia.
Les he contado muchas cosas terribles.
Y piensan, "Dios mío, es horrible: ¿Qué puedo hacer al respecto?"
Bueno, por suerte,
hemos identificado que hay un problema.
Hay falta de oportunidades y eso se debe al sesgo inconsciente.
Pero podrían estar sentados allí pensando:
"No soy de color. ¿Qué tiene esto que ver conmigo?"
Permítanme ofrecerles una solución.
Y como he dicho antes,
vivimos en un mundo donde estamos buscando un ideal.
Y si queremos crear un mundo
donde las circunstancias del nacimiento no importen,
todos tenemos que ser parte de la solución.
Y curiosamente, la autora del experimento del currículum
ofreció una solución.
Dijo que en lo único en que coincidían las mujeres de éxito,
lo único que tenían en común,
fue el hecho de haber tenido buenos mentores.
Así que la tutoría, todos hemos oído eso antes,
es algo propio.
Aquí hay otro reto para Uds.
Les reto a todos y cada uno de Uds. a guiar a alguien diferente.
Piensen en ello.
Todo el mundo quiere ser mentor de alguien que le resulta familiar,
que se parece a nosotros, con el que compartimos experiencias.
Si veo a una chica musulmana con algo de actitud, diría:
"¿Qué pasa? ¿Quedamos?"
Si entran en una habitación y hay alguien que fue a la misma escuela,
que practica los mismos deportes,
hay gran probabilidad de que quiera ayudarla.
Pero para la persona en la habitación
que no tiene experiencias compartidas con Uds.,
se vuelve extremadamente difícil encontrar esa conexión.
La idea de encontrar a alguien diferente al mentor,
alguien que no viene del mismo entorno,
cualquiera que sea este,
es abrir puertas para la gente que no podía ni siquiera llegar
al bendito pasillo.
Porque señoras y señores, el mundo no es justo.
Las personas no nacen con igualdad de oportunidades.
Nací en una de las ciudades más pobres del mundo, Jartum.
Nací marrón, nací mujer,
y nací musulmana en un mundo que sospecha bastante de nosotros
por razones que no puedo controlar.
Sin embargo, también reconozco el hecho de nacer con privilegios.
Nací con unos padres increíbles,
me dieron una educación
y tuve la suerte de emigrar a Australia.
Pero también, he sido afortunada con mentores increíbles
que abrieron puertas para mí, que ni siquiera sabía que estaban allí.
Un mentor que me dijo: "Oye, es interesante tu historia,
vamos a escribir algo al respecto para que pueda compartirlo con la gente".
Otro dijo:
"Sé que representas todas esas cosas
que no se encuentran en una plataforma australiana pero vamos a intentarlo".
Y aquí estoy, hablando con Uds. Y no soy la única.
Hay todo tipo de personas a mi alrededor
que han sido ayudadas por sus mentores.
Un joven musulmán en Sídney
que terminó usando la ayuda de su mentor
para poner en marcha un certamen de poesía en Bankstown
y ahora es algo enorme.
Y puede cambiar la vida de tantos otros jóvenes.
O una señora aquí en Brisbane,
una señora afgana refugiada,
que apenas sabía hablar inglés cuando llegó a Australia,
sus mentores le ayudaron a convertirse en médico
y fue elegida Joven del Año 2008 en Queensland.
Es una inspiración.
Esto no es fácil.
Esta soy yo.
Pero también soy la mujer que llevaba el equipo de trabajo,
y también soy la mujer que llevaba el abaya al principio.
¿Me hubiera elegido mi mentor de haberme visto
en una de esas otras versiones de lo que soy?
Porque soy la misma persona.
Tenemos que mirar más allá de nuestro sesgo inconsciente,
encontrar un discípulo que esté en el extremo opuesto del espectro,
porque el cambio estructural requiere tiempo,
y yo no tengo ese nivel de paciencia.
Así que si vamos a crear un cambio,
si vamos a crear un mundo
donde todos tenemos ese tipo de oportunidades,
entonces opten por abrir puertas a la gente.
Porque podrían pensar que la diversidad no tiene nada que ver con Uds.,
pero todos somos parte de este sistema
y todos podemos ser parte de la solución.
Y si no saben dónde encontrar a alguien diferente,
vayan a lugares a los que no suelen ir.
Si se inscriben en tutorías en escuelas privadas de secundaria,
vayan a una escuela estatal local
o tal vez solo pasen por el centro de tutoría local para refugiados.
O tal vez trabajan en una oficina.
Ayuden a ese nuevo graduado que parece totalmente fuera de lugar
--porque esa era yo-- y abra puertas para ellos,
no de manera simbólica, porque no somos víctimas,
sino para mostrarles las oportunidades,
porque la apertura de sus mundos
les hará darse cuenta de que tienen acceso a puertas
que ni siquiera sabían que existían
y Uds. no sabían tampoco que ellos no lo sabían.
Señoras y señores,
hay un problema en nuestra comunidad con la falta de oportunidades,
especialmente debido al sesgo inconsciente.
Pero todos y cada uno de Uds. tiene el potencial de cambiar eso.
Sé que les he planteado una gran cantidad de desafíos hoy,
pero si pueden aceptar esto y pensar un poco diferente,
la diversidad es la magia.
Y les animo a mirar más allá de sus percepciones iniciales
porque, les apuesto lo que quieran,
a que son probablemente equivocadas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)